The database we'll be working with in this course is:
MongoDB. There are a couple of reasons for that. One of
which is, since I work for MongoDB it would be bizarre
for me to do this using a different database and potentially
a career limiting move. But, the primary reason for talking
about MongoDB in this particular course is because it makes a
lot of sense for data analysis applications. MongoDB is widely used
in big data. And, it's the leading no SQL database. Now,
while MongoDB is a no SQL database. The term
we, we most commonly use is document database. Let me
talk a little bit about what we mean by that.
We're not talking about a database for storing PDF documents
or Microsoft Word documents. What we mean by documents is
an associative array. Now, this is the same type of
structure that you see in a JSON object. Or a
PHP array. A Python dictionary or Ruby hash, and similar
data structures in other programming languages. MongoDB allows
us to store these types of hierarchical data structures.
Directly in the database as individual items or
documents. Now the documents stored in mongoDB use a
JSON like syntax. I say JSON like because
mongoDB is more flexible with the use of quotes
and other small syntaxical elements than strict JSON.
And yes, it is somewhat oxymoronic to describe anything
Javascript related as strict.